You don't need to just choose one family to support
in Operation Olive Branch.
This is what the, like,
Google Excel sheet looks like, right?
There's navigations to every little piece of Operation Olive Branch.
This is right now for, like,
mothers who just had children or are going to have children soon.
This is where you would go to help those families.
If you wanna help people who have disabilities or medical issues,
you would go to this page
and then it goes and explains their circumstances and, like,
you can see how much money is left,
like, necessary for their funding,
what the family is, like,
who they are. It's. All of this information is laid out for you, like,
you know, easily accessible on Operation Olive Branch.
This is for mutual aid.
This is for the first responders, right?
Health care workers,
doctors, like, Red Cross.
Like, this is Red Crescent.
This is, like, if you wanna help them, right?
Like, each of these little areas
will give you an information on a new group of people that
if you want to help,
you can. Right?
I feel like maybe some people
are feeling daunted by the idea of adopting a family, right?
This. This might help you.
Right here is a master list.
If you don't wanna choose,
if you don't wanna,
you know, go at random,
you can. There are 800 and like 80 something families, not.
Not individuals,
families that have been vetted.
You can have all their Information,
their socials.
You have their ages,
their stories.
You can have like their go fund me's,
how much is left until they reach their goal.
It is all, all here,
right here.
And I understand if you feel daunted by choosing just one group,
if you don't wanna fill the whatever,
whatever the reason,
if for some reason you can only donate one time
or you can only share one thing,
like, just share it as a whole operation Olive Branch.
Like I, I think that this is a really great resource to be using.
And you can see like I.
When I wanna donate,
I just go and I look at like, who hasn't,
you know, had a lot of movement,
who has like the least amount of donations.
I usually donate to those groups. Or if I feel like,
you know, maybe someone's about to reach their goal,
then you can donate there.
Whatever you feel like doing,
just you can go through and you can choose
and you can read all the stories
and these are all individual,
real life people and families that need help.
And like,
all of this work has been done till to make it so easily accessible.
There's no reason to say that you cannot help
support people in Palestine
because it does all the work for you.
Like, these people have been vetted,
you know their story,
you know, you know everything, right?
This is what it is, right?
It's all Right here.
I understand, again,
not knowing where to start.
This is where you go.
Go. Like,
they did all the work for you.
If you're waiting right now for,
you know, to adopt a family,
you can still help.
You can still share this page.
I genuinely think, like,
all the information is right here.
A lot of these families are trying to escape Palestine,
but let's not forget that they should not be doing that.
Like, these people are being ripped away from their homes.
And, like, ultimately, yes,
like, humanitarian aid is important,
but what we need is a ceasefire and end to the occupation.
And ultimately, we just need, like,
Palestinians to be able to live on their own land.
And it's unfortunate that the only choice they have right now
is to flee, because despite the world seeing what is happening,
United States has not stopped supporting Israel.
Israel continues to harm Palestinians.
And somehow we live in a timeline where people have to
crowd source to escape a genocide.
At this point,
the only thing that's really in our control
is helping these individuals get to safety,
get their families to safety,
and support in what ways we can directly.
And I'm glad that we're at a point
where creators are speaking out about this.